en este vídeo vamos a analizar otra
configuración común de resistencias que
se llama resistencias en paralelo en
este dibujo tenemos dos resistencias en
paralelo esta resistencia está en
paralelo a esta otra resistencia y la
razón de esto es que estas dos
resistencias comparten los mismos nodos
por lo que ambas comparten el mismo
voltaje es por eso que estas
resistencias están en paralelo lo
escribimos si comparten los mismos nodos
entonces comparten el mismo voltaje y
por lo tanto están en paralelo esto es
lo que significa este término si
analizamos esto con cuidado encontramos
cosas interesantes en la batería tenemos
un voltaje v y debido a que hay una ruta
completa aquí va a haber una corriente
tenemos la corriente que fluye por el
circuito vamos a etiquetar las
resistencias esta es r 1 y esta es r 2
las resistencias están en paralelo si
vemos este punto cuando la corriente
llega a este nodo se va a dividir en dos
corrientes una que va por aquí y otra
que se va por acá
a este le llamamos y uno porque pasa por
la resistencia 1 y esta es 2 porque pasa
por la resistencia 2 sabemos que la
corriente que pasa por una resistencia
sale del otro lado de otra manera se
quedaría en la resistencia y sabemos que
esto no ocurre estas corrientes salen
por acá y llegan a este mismo nodo aquí
abajo está la corriente y que es la
misma que está arriba ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es reemplazar estas resistencias
con una resistencia de equivalente una
sola resistencia que se comporte igual
que estas dos es decir que ocasione la
misma corriente que fluye en el circuito
principal esto es lo que tenemos
dibujado de este lado aquí hay una
resistencia de este lado tenemos el
mismo voltaje v y a esta resistencia
equivalente le llamamos resistencia
paralela erp y esta resistencia ocasiona
que fluya esta corriente y por aquí y
ahora vamos a desarrollar una expresión
para calcular rpm en términos de estas
dos resistencias en paralelo de acá
analicemos lo que conocemos de esta
parte del circuito
sabemos que el voltaje en ambas
resistencias es el mismo
que hay dos corrientes diferentes
suponiendo que estas dos resistencias
son de valores diferentes con toda esta
información podemos aplicar la ley de
ohm que es nuestra ley favorita la ley
de ohm dice que el voltaje es igual a la
corriente que pasa por la resistencia
multiplicado por el valor de esa
resistencia vamos a escribir la ley de
ohm para r1 y r2 conocemos que el
voltaje es v para r 1 v es igual a 1 por
r uno para r 2 la misma v es igual a y 2
por efe 2 otra cosa más que sabemos es
que y uno más y 2 es igual a y lo
escribimos esto es todo lo que conocemos
de este circuito
ahora vamos a encontrar una expresión
para y 1 y 2 con base en estas
expresiones y las vamos a sustituir en
esta ecuación despejamos y 1 de esta
expresión y queda igual a v entre r 1 y
si despejamos y 2 queda igual a v entre
r 2 sustituimos estas dos expresiones
acá y nos queda que y es igual hay uno
que es v entre r uno más v entre
reescribimos esta expresión como igual a
v que multiplica a 1 entre r 1 más 1
entre r 2 tenemos esta nueva expresión
que se parece bastante a la ley de ohm
tiene un término y un término v y un
término con el es veamos la ley de ohm
original y vamos a despejar y en
términos de v para que se vea más obvio
y es igual a v entre r espero que puedan
ver la semejanza que hay entre esta
expresión y la expresión de aquí abajo
aquí tenemos esta ere y el término de
aquí abajo es equivalente a la
resistencia de arriba escribimos esta
expresión aquí abajo y es igual a v por
1 entre r aunque esta r en realidad es
rp quiero hacer que esta expresión sea
igual a esta otra tenemos la misma y la
misma v y estos términos también son
iguales 1 / erp es igual a 1 / r 1 + 1 /
r 2 esto quiere decir que tenemos una
resistencia erp o r paralelo que se
comporta como la combinación en paralelo
de r
y r2 esta es la expresión de una
resistencia en paralelo si queremos
encontrar un reemplazo o una resistencia
equivalente a r1 y r2 que están en
paralelo hacemos este cálculo y
obtenemos erp hagamos un ejemplo aquí
tenemos el mismo circuito pero ahora con
valores en sus elementos hay una
resistencia de 2011 en paralelo con una
resistencia de 60 oms por lo que pasa un
voltaje de 3 voltios lo que queremos
hacer es combinar estas resistencias en
paralelo y calcular la corriente que
pasa por el circuito la corriente es la
incógnita usemos la ecuación 1 entre rp
es igual a 1 entre r uno más uno entre r
2 sustituimos los números uno entre rp
es igual a uno entre 20 más uno entre 60
esto es igual a si 60 es el denominador
común entonces multiplicamos esto por 3
y queda 3 entre 60 más 1 entre 60 esto
es igual a 4 entre 60 ahora tomamos el
recíproco
rp es igual a 60 entre 4 y si hacemos la
división
en erp igual a 15 oms si tenemos dos
resistencias en paralelo una de 20 oms y
otra de 60 oms y queremos calcular la
corriente del circuito podemos
reemplazar estas resistencias en
paralelo por una sola resistencia de 15
oms vamos a completar el circuito
equivalente y ahora sí vamos a calcular
la corriente la corriente es igual al
voltaje entre la resistencia sustituimos
y nos queda 3 volts entre 15 oms lo que
nos da 0.2 amperes o es igual a 200.000
amperes simplificamos el circuito de dos
resistencias a una resistencia y pudimos
calcular la corriente que pasa por él
que es de 0.2 amperes los invito a que
verifiquen esto calculando la corriente
del circuito de aquí arriba y confirmar
que es la misma esto se hace calculando
la corriente que pasa por cada
resistencia aquí la corriente es igual a
3 volts a través de 20 oms y acá la
corriente es igual a 3 volts a través de
60 oms así obtienen y 1 y 2 y al
sumarlas tendrán la corriente total que
debe ser igual a cero
todo sanz pérez este es un buen
ejercicio para que ustedes comprueben
que la expresión para una resistencia en
paralelo 1 / r paralelo es igual a 1 / r
1 + 1 / r 2 nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo